these are the best or the worst time in
the whole wide world to start that's
right we will know we will know and you
guys like to gamble that's correct it's
crazy how it all started we've won three
races in in lat in the year and three
quarters that we've been in the sport
because it's so hard to win in NASCAR
let alone when you just start a team
this is not easy in Ford versus Ferrari
people were like oh my gosh Is that real
I'm like it's harder than what they made
it look like there's more politics than
what they make it look like I was like
they just built a car to go win at Le
Mans like that does not happen I know
it's so impressive what you've done you
know we already punched our ticket in
the owners Championship to the next
round uh with Bubba Wallace so it's just
uh really been amazing the run that
we've been on and bringing on Kurt Busch
was just one of the best things we ever
did are you more surprised to be winning
races three wins at this point in time
with that with not even being completed
with the second season do you more
surprised the bubble one that is a great
question